good morning everyone as Elvis said I'm
the director of IBM Research Cambridge
it's literally just a few blocks down
the road I've worked probably 20 years
and IBM research primarily out of our
New York lab but I moved here just three
months ago to really start up this new
AI lab refocus and significantly grow
the Cambridge lab that we've we've
already started I intentionally chose a
somewhat provocative title to my talk
today the reason I wanted the the beyond
deep learning it's not necessarily to
say that you know all of these deep
learning techniques are going to be you
know obsolete that's definitely not what
I'm trying to say but I am trying to say
that you know although there's a lot of
exciting things that we can do with deep
learning today there's also a frontier
you know a space that we can't do very
well and so I hope to today talk to you
about you know kind of what is an area
of a boundary that we we're not able to
break through at this time that I think
is is critical for machine intelligence
for artificial general intelligence so
I'm hoping that today I can set that up
for you hopefully you know motivate
additional people to come in and study
this because I really believe that it's
a it's a critical area where where
additional breakthroughs are needed I'd
like to first introduce IBM Research I
don't know
how many of you actually know about IBM
research some of you may have heard of
us because of the Jeopardy challenge so
in 2011 we created a computer that was
able to beat the chest I mean the
jeopardy champions at that game
very handily as as a matter of fact some
people don't realize that our research
division is it's quite significant so we
have 3,000 people worldwide 12 labs that
are doing this research researchers
pursue the same types of accolades that
you
the top university professors go after
so nobody laureates touring awards
National Academy of Sciences National
Academy of technologies so we pursue a
very you know rigorous you know set of
research in the areas that we focus on
oh and although I put the the Jeopardy
challenge up there you're only as good
as your your most recent results right
so I also wanted to make sure that I
talked a little bit about things that
we've done more recently so in 2017 as
an example we created the first 50 cubit
quantum computer most people are kind of
you know I expect to actually see some
people announcing some other companies
announcing simulators for 50 on the
order of 50 cubits and the difference
here is that we're talking about an
actual 50 cubit quantum computer so we
we also have the simulators but we have
the real quantum computers I think
what's also unique about what we're
doing is that we are also making our
quantum computing capabilities available
through the cloud so that people can
kind of login and they can experiment
and learn about what quantum computing
is it's a very exciting program for us
we also in 2017 we were able to show
near linear scale out in terms of you
know cafe deep learning models on on our
servers we were able to show algorithms
that were able to exploit the quantum
advantage so the idea is that if you in
order to actually get the speed ups on
quantum computers you need to be able to
map problems into a form where you can
get that acceleration and when you get
that acceleration then you're talking
about exponential accelerations over
traditional computers that people are
using today so this particular result
was an algorithm that's able to
basically map small molecules models of
small molecules on to the actual quantum
computing system so that we could
demonstrate the ability to find the
lowest energy state so
and and get that exponential speed-up
from that you know the thing is that in
2017 we rename number one leading
corporation for scientific in you know
scientific research at AI that corporate
Institute so that's that's pretty
exciting for us I also wanted to just
tell you a little bit about the MIT
Watson MIT IBM Watson AI lab it's
obviously a very exciting announcement
for us so in September of 2017 we
announced that we were building this 240
million dollar joint effort with MIT to
pursue fundamental advances in AI the
core areas are listed here so when I say
fundamental advances in AI that it's
really again recognizing what we can and
can't do with AI today and then trying
to create new algorithms to go beyond
that so examples of problems just very
quickly that we're interested in in
terms of the the new AI lab one area is
that you know learning causal structure
from data is a very challenging problem
we're looking at how we can use data
that was captured due to CRISPR
mediations our CRISPR gene in
activations which basically has very
large set of interventional data where
they're observing the whole genome and
we're going to try to learn a causal
structure you know from those those
interventions so that's that's one
example another example in physics of AI
basically what we're talking about there
is the ability to have AI help quantum
computing and quantum computers and
quantum computers accelerate AI
algorithms so we're looking at problems
for example machine learning algorithms
that would help us to manage the state
of the quantum computer also looking at
for example the ability to knowing what
we know about quantum computers knowing
that you know we're gonna be in the
small numbers of hundreds of qubits for
some time that the memory bandwidth
between traditional computers and the
quantum
kut'rs can be relative small which of
the machine learning algorithms will we
be able to map on to those systems in
order to get that exponential speed-up
so those are just some of the examples
of things that we're studying also we we
feel that right now there are two
industries that are really ripe for AI
disruption one is healthcare life
sciences the reason they're ripe for
disruption is because that community has
invested a lot to create what we refer
to as structured knowledge so you know
gene ontology you know sno-med clinical
terms all of the structured knowledge
that we can combine with observational
data and create new algorithms and
insecurity the reason why cybersecurity
the reason why that one is ripe for
disruption is because if everybody is
advancing these AI algorithms and people
start to try to use those AI algorithms
to attack our systems it's very
important that we also use AI algorithms
to try to figure out how they're going
to do that and how to defend against
that so through some of the examples the
last one shared prosperity is about how
do we get non-discrimination on bias
morals into the algorithms not just
training on for you know scale-out and
accuracy and these sorts of things all
right we we already had our first
announcement in terms of the new MIT IBM
Watson AI lab so at nips we announced
that we are releasing a 1 million video
data set the idea for those of you are
familiar and you've probably learned a
lot in this class about how people used
image net to make new breakthroughs in
terms of deep learning just that volume
of labeled data meant that people could
go in and run experiments and train
networks that they could never do before
so we've created this this million video
dataset 3-second videos were chosen for
a specific reason the lead for this
project o deliver is has great expertise
not only in computer science but also in
cognitive science and so it's expected
that you know three seconds is roughly
the order of times that it takes humans
to recognize certain actions as well so
we're we're kind of sticking with that
time
Computers aren't the machine learning
algorithms that you were learning about
today aren't able to do this well you
know what you primarily learned about so
far was how to segment images how to
find objects within images how to
classify those those objects but not
actions and the reason why we also think
that actions are important is because
they are composable right so we want to
be able to learn not just elemental
actions from these videos but then to
start to think about how you recognize
and attack compositions of actions and
procedures that people are performing
because then we can use that to start to
teach the computers to also perform
those procedures or to help humans to be
able to perform those procedures better
okay now what I want to do is maybe take
a break from kind of the set up and get
into the more technical part of the of
the talk today so as I was saying
earlier you know what we've seen
recently in deep learning is is truly
all inspiring I mean in terms of the
number of breakthroughs over over the
last ten years and especially over the
last five years it is very exciting you
know breakthroughs in terms of you know
being able to for certain tasks you know
beat human error rates in terms of you
know visual recognition and speech
speech recognition and so on but my
position is that there are still huge
breakthroughs that are required to try
to get to machine intelligence so some
examples of challenges that the systems
of today aren't able to do so one is
that many many of the scenarios in order
to get the performance that actually is
is usable requires labeled data it
requires training data where you've
actually labeled the the objects and the
images and so on while the systems are
getting better in terms of doing
unsupervised learning because of the
vast amount of data that's available on
the web the problem is that we at IBM
care about AI for businesses right and
if you think of AI for businesses
there's
not that much deep domain data that
we're able to find try it so if you
think about the medical field very deep
expressive relations that are required
to be understood acquires a lot of
labeled data you know if you think of
you know an airline manufacturer and all
of the the manuals they may have and
they'd like to try to be able to answer
questions from those and be able to
reason and help humans understand how to
conduct procedures within those there's
not enough data out there on those
fields in terms of relationships and
entities and so on for us to train so it
requires a lot of labeling humans
actually going through and finding the
important entities and relationships and
so on so an important area that we need
to be able to break through is first of
all why why why do these machines why do
these networks require so much data
label data and can we can we address
that can we make the algorithms better
the second thing is that you've probably
realized that you you train up the
algorithms and then they're able to
perform some tasks the tasks are getting
more and more sophisticated self-driving
cars and so on but you're still not
training this network so that it can
perform many different tasks and even
more importantly what happens is that
you learn a model and even though you
may as part of the training you may have
reinforcement learning
that's not lifelong learning that's not
just you know turning the cars out on
the road and enabling them to continue
to learn and aggregate information and
bring that into a representation so that
they can adapt to you know
non-stationary environments environments
that change over time another thing is
that you know when we train these
networks you kind of get it down to a
certain error rate but how do you keep
improving the accuracy even though the
error rates not that bad
algorithms don't don't do well at this
today and then the last area is that
it's really important that we're
creating algorithms that are interacting
with the humans right that can explain
how they may have come to a particular
decision or classification or whatever
the case may be so we need to try to
think about how can we build machines
that
and learn they can listen interact with
the humans be able to explain their
their decisions to humans and so a big
part of this is what we were what I
refer to many in the community referred
to as you know learning plus reasoning
meaning that we want to be able to
reason on representations that are
learned preferably on representations
that are learned in an unsupervised
manner all right the first step in doing
that is to be able to make language
itself computational right so we are
able to think about you know words as
sort of symbols and what those words
mean and the properties of them and then
reason about them if you think about all
the algorithms that you've been learning
they expect the information to be coming
to them as as numerical information
preferably as real valued information
how do you go from text to real valued
information that can then be fed into
these algorithms over time and then
computed on so one of the you know the
first areas here is is word embeddings
the reason i italicized word is because
what you'll see is that we kind of
started out with word embeddings but now
it's you know phrase embeddings document
embedding so there's much more to this
but let's let's start first with what do
we mean with word embeddings okay the
point is to try to represent a word as a
real valued vector that basically
represents what that words means in
terms of other words right so so the the
dimensions of that vector the features
are basically other words and the point
is that you can assign different weights
on how well that word relates to these
other words okay so now the difficult
part there is how do you learn that
representation that's going to give you
that objective of making that vector
really represent that word and be
comparable to other words in a way that
the machine can can compute on them so
the idea is the first work earlier work
in this was
all right how do we do this such that
those embeddings those vectors give you
an understanding of the similarity
between this word and other words within
your dictionary first model here was
what they refer to as a skip gram model
basically what you try to do is you say
give it a particular word how well can I
predict the words around it the words
that are one hop away from it two hop
away from it three hops away from it
what they're trying to do is to train a
set of vectors where you minimize the
the the loss the prediction loss of
being able to predict the words around
it based off of that word there's a very
big difference for the community
previously it had been mostly counts
people just kind of count the number of
occurrences and then they would use that
to try to almost make that two wait what
this was doing was taking a deep neural
network well it was actually kind of a
shallow neural network to try to
optimize or maximize this log
probability of being able to predict the
words around it from that and what they
got from that is what you can kind of
see here this ability to place words
symbols into a vector space such that
words that are similar or closer
together
right so the point is you can see and
and also that relationships between
words you know move in similar
directions right so what this figure is
trying to show you is that you know you
can look at the countries that are here
on the on the left side and you can see
that they're similar the ones that are
all countries are proximal the cities
are proximal the you know the the vector
that is going from countries to city are
you know essentially going in the same
direction I'm sure I'm not sure if you
can actually see that but the point is
that this kind of a vector space gives
us the ability to compute on those real
valued vectors and then learn more about
this so a very first simple thing is to
be able to you know
be able to find other similar things
right you have you have something you
have a symbol Italy for example can you
find other things that are similar to or
related to Italy you can find other
countries you can find cities within
Italy that's the that's kind of the
first step the you know so the first the
first work there was this kind of
distributed representation that we're
talking about here the second is
basically showing the difference in
terms of being able to second talk as a
paper was about the accuracy the
significant jump in accuracy that we got
from being able to do that prediction
based representation as opposed to the
count based representation I put I
signaled you know IBM authors people who
are at or were at IBM in orange and the
last one is the Facebook has actually
recently released this fast text where
you can basically go in and very easily
create your own embeddings so first
thing was you know how do they create it
and they went after a specific thing how
do you optimize that similarity but what
you'll see from the rest of the talk is
that there are many other ways that you
might want to try to figure out how to
place things together other constraints
that you might want to place on the
vector space and how things are
represented in that vector space so that
you can accomplish tasks from it prior
to these types of representation the
ideals for how people would actually go
after representing knowledge and
language were knowledge bases structured
knowledge so our original ideas was
alright listen I have to be able to have
entities that are well defined I have to
have well-defined relationships between
those entities I have to have rules that
basically will give me information about
you know categories of relationships or
categories of entities and it's great
humans are able to do that they're out
able to lay out an entire space you know
describe you know molecules and
relationships between molecules or genes
or relationships between genes and the
targets that they might be able to
humans can do that well machines don't
do it that Wow
that was the problem so the second
figure here was even though you you know
you kind of go out and you're able to
find a lot of things in Wikipedia and
wicked Atta you know freebase or some of
the examples where you can find
structured information on the web even
though you're able to find a lot of
information out here and although this
is a 2013 statement what you can see is
that in terms of the types of
relationships and completeness of that
this is saying okay well for the people
that are in Wikipedia or in freebase
actually we only we're missing about 80
percent of their their education where
their education is from we're missing
you know over 90 percent of their
employment history right so even though
it seems like it's a lot of information
it's really sparse and very difficult
for humans to be able to use the
algorithms that we have today to
automatically populate knowledge bases
that look like the form that we
understand and feel that we can apply
our logic to so one of the first results
in terms of going from that symbolic
knowledge into sub symbolic knowledge so
the vectors that I was talking about
earlier was could we redo our knowledge
bases based off of these sub symbolic
these these vectors if we were able to
do that then we actually would be able
to learn much more data it's possible we
could learn these these representations
and fill out some of the the information
that we're missing from our knowledge
bases this first part was saying okay
look I can take some of the information
I can find in freebase and other sources
what I'll do is I can use text
information to try to build out these
embeddings I can find relationships or I
can find entities that are in similar
spaces and realize there may be a
relationship between these and I can
start to populate more of the
relationships that I'm that I'm missing
from my knowledge base
we're able to use this this this
principle of the the embeddings and the
knowledgebase is to then start to grow
the knowledge bases that we have right
so this is basic the first study here is
showing how we took information about
genes diseases and drugs from ontologies
that were available represented that
learn vectors across that structured
space so that we could predict
relationships that weren't in the
knowledge base that's important because
if you think about how people get that
information today they actually do wet
lab experiments to try to understand if
there is a relationship if something up
regulates something else it's very
expensive if we can use this knowledge
to make those predictions then we can
give other scientists places to look
looks like there might be an interaction
here maybe you could try that right the
second set of results is more recent
basically there was a challenge issued
by the Semantic Web community how can we
better improve this automated knowledge
based construction so the team used a
combination of these word embeddings to
be able to search for and validate
information gained from a set of
structured and unstructured knowledge so
this is actually one first place in the
in the 2017 semantic web challenge okay
so now we were kind of getting an idea
about how we would take language make it
computational put it into a knowledge
base so that we can aggregate it over
time but how are we going to get the
neural networks to use that that's the
next question okay an example task of
why you would want those neural networks
to be able to use that is question
answering you want to build up a
knowledge base everything you can
possibly find and then you want to be
able to ask your questions and see if it
can answer those questions we say that
this requires memories because the point
is that if you think about some of the
other tasks that you may have seen
you provide once you've trained the
network you provide an input and then
you get an output you don't necessarily
use long term memories of relationships
and entities and all of these sorts of
things okay so this is a challenge that
was issued to the community essentially
in terms of being able to read some
sentences and then being able to given a
question give an answer to that and
there are different stages of the
complexity of what is required in order
to answer the question sometimes it's
really just kind of finding the sentence
sometimes it's being able to put
multiple sentences together sometimes
it's being able to chain across time and
so there are many there's stages of
difficulties in order to do that but
what I want to focus on is some of the
early work in terms of creating a neural
network that can then access those
knowledge bases and then be able to
produce an answer from that right so the
expectation is that you you build up
those knowledge bases from as much
information you can find previously you
train them such that they know how to
answer a question the types of questions
that you'd like them to answer and then
from that when you you handed a question
it's able to produce an answer the
reason this is different from what
people are doing today it's not just
about saying today what happens is you
know when you program a computer then
you tell it okay I want to be able to
access this place in memory you know I
do a query on a database and I say okay
I'd like for you to give me all the rows
where the first name is is excellent the
last name is why it can come back and
that's all programmed these networks are
instead learning how to access memory by
looking at other patterns of access to
memory not program train it train so the
point here is the neural net is the
controller of how that memory is
accessed in order to produce an answer
okay
so what happens is that they they it is
a supervised result so they they do
train jointly with okay what are the
inputs
what's the question that would be asked
of that what's the output that is
desired from that and then by providing
many many many examples of that then
when you provided a new set of
information then it's able to to answer
a question from that by basically taking
a vector representation of the question
cue being able to map that on to the
memory so the embeddings that were
produced from all the sentences that
were entered and then moving back and
forth across that until it gets to a
confidence that in an answer and
transferring that into into an output on
the first version of this the first
version that's on the left side wasn't
able to handle many things in terms of
understanding you know kind of temporal
sequences for example they weren't able
to do multi-hop and the second version
which is much more recent is you know
kind of fool into n training of that
control of the of the network in order
to try to start to answer these
questions while it's it's incredibly
exciting you know there's still many of
the questions that I was showing earlier
that it really can't answer so this is
definitely not a solve problem but you
know hopefully what you can see is that
how we're starting to go up against
problems that we don't know completely
how to solve but we're starting to solve
them and instead of just creating neural
networks just an algorithm we are
creating machines right we're creating
machines that have controllers and they
have memory and they're able to perform
tasks that go well beyond just what you
could do with the pure neural network
algorithm they they leverage those
neural network out algorithms throughout
these are recurrent neural Nets LST ions
and so on but the point is we're
starting to try to put together machines
from this if you if you'd like to learn
more about this topic there's there's
quite a bit of work in this so one is in
addition to being able to answer those
questions if we could better isolate
what's the question right this is
something that that humans have a
problem with Jim somebody comes and they
ask you a question and you kind of say
well wait what what's
the question your you're asking here so
we've done work in terms of being able
to have better the computers better
understand what's the question really
being asks we need systems that will
help us to train these models so part of
this work is to create a simulator that
can take texts that are ambiguous and
generate questions of certain forms that
we can then use that to try to both
train as well as test some of these
systems another really interesting thing
is that common-sense knowledge is
basically you know they refer to it as
what's in the white space between what
you read right you read a text and a lot
of times there's a lot of common sense
knowledge you know knowing that you know
you know this desk is made of wood and
wood is hard and all of these sorts of
things help you to understand a question
you can't find that it's it's not on
Wikipedia muster that common sense
information is not not on Wikipedia it's
not easy for us to learn from text
because people don't state it this this
third work here is okay can we take some
of that common sense knowledge can we
learn in vector space ways to represent
information that's common sense that
that white space and attach it to other
information that that we're able to read
from from the web and so on now some of
the recent work as well as can we can we
use neural nets to basically learn what
a program is doing represent that and
then be able to execute that program
programs you know this right now people
want to try to program program that
takes a very sophisticated human skill
to be able to probe probe a program and
understand it and in fact humans don't
do that very well but if we could train
machines to do that and obviously that's
a very powerful thing to do we're also a
paper that was just published a couple a
couple of months ago in December at nib
so I thought was extremely interesting
basically they're learning how to
constrain vector representations such
that they can in
new rules from those and that they can
basically create proofs right so when
you the reason a proof is important is
basically that's the beginnings of being
able to explain an answer so when if you
ask a question of the question from some
of the other ones was you know it's it's
the apples in the kitchen why I think
you have a proof if you have the steps
that you went through in terms of the
knowledge base able to explain that out
then suddenly people can interact with
the the system and use the system not
only to answer questions but to improve
and lift what what humans the human
knowledge as well learn learn from the
computers right now the computers learn
from us and just finally if you'd like
to do more you know the research
division is working on next-generation
algorithms those come out through our
Watson products we have a Watson
developer cloud makes it very easy you
know you can do things like you handed
an image and it'll hand back information
about what's in that image you you hand
it text it'll tell you information about
the sentiment of that you know label
information within it and so on so we
have what we believe are very easy to
use
you know algorithms that take many of
these things that were I was talking
about earlier and make them very easy
for anyone to use and incorporate in
into their programs I think that's it
for me
[Applause]